it was interesting a few weeks ago I was  visited in Hawaii by none other than  Carl Sagan and he had a number of things  on his mind  one of the things that he was at great  pains to point out to me was I said  something about this asymptotic approach  to the end of history and he said well  my dear boy you just have it all wrong  the speed of information transfer  reached the speed of light with the  invention of radio it's been absolutely  flat ever since the largest thermal  nuclear blast ever detonated was in 1958  there hasn't been a bigger one for 30  years the fastest human object ever  built was launched in 1967 in a faster  one sense so this nonsense about ever  increasing this that and the other is  just doesn't hold water